l'europe avance à strasbourg 11 des 12
pays de la cee sont d'accord pour
l'union monétaire et la charte sociale
l'allemagne a dit oui à nagui à l'est
les partis communistes de plus en plus
fiévreux congrès extraordinaire ce soir
à berlin est et réunion d'urgence des
comités centraux demain à moscou et à
sofia en bulgarie
l'un des huit évadés de la prison de
lannemezan a été arrêté ce midi dans les
hautes-pyrénées ses compagnons de cavale
aurait tenté d old latran antarctique à
deux pas du pôle le docteur etienne et
son équipe devraient toucher au but dans
quatre ou cinq
madame monsieur bonsoir l'europe avance
donc à strasbourg malgré l'opposition de
londres et de margaret thatcher auquel
les onze autres pays de la cee se sont
habitués il y as accord pour une
conférence sur l'union monétaire avant
la fin 1990 et accord sur la charte
sociale dans ce sommet dominé par les
bouleversements intervenus à l'est et
leurs conséquences sur l'allemagne
le chancelier kohl en acceptant ce pas
en avant vers l'union monétaire rassure
ses partenaires de la communauté
européenne à strasbourg
on a donc parlé d'union monétaire charte
sociale et pour la première fois aussi
immigration le compte rendu de cette
journée avec philippe sassier
de quoi parle-t-on dans un déjeuner
officiel et bien aujourd'hui sous les
lambris des salons du fameux cardinal de
rohan on a beaucoup parlé de lui
mais chut mitterrand galles cher
andreotti les derniers à l'avoir vu
soulever bien des curiosités
il sait mirel gorbatchev participantes
invisible mais omniprésent à ce sommet
strasbourgeois pour la construction de
l'europe de l'ouest se mêle à la
reconstruction de celles de l'est au
moment de la photo de famille en fin de
matinée on ne savait pas encore comment
les événements à l'est allait influer
sur les discussions des 12
on savait que maggie thatcher de murray
opposé à l'idée d'une monnaie européenne
unique et à l'adoption de la charte
sociale
la position du chancelier kohl
apparaissait plus ambigu un an des
élections en allemagne et l'essai de
ménager la chèvre nationaliste et de
chou européen mais ce soir à l'issue
d'une journée de travail les choses
paraissent être clarifiées 11 pays sur
douze sont d'accord pour que soit
convoqué avant la fin de 1990 une
conférence intergouvernementale pour
renégocier le traité de rome afin d'y
introduire l'idée de l'unité économique
et monétaire c'est un nouveau pas qui va
être franchie vers la monnaie unique
avec nous en direct de strasbourg
georges bortoli georges
apparemment je ne vous voit pas mais je
vais vous entendre georges voilà
l'allemagne apparemment s'est donc
engagée dans l'union monétaire
c'était une façon de rassurer ses
partenaires ou est européen
mais dans le même temps elle leur dit il
faut que vous engagez vous sur l'unité
allemande
à terme alors est ce que ça veut dire
que l'incertitude qui présidait ce matin
au début des débats de ce sommet à
strasbourg
est-ce que c'est fini est ce que les
divergences sont aplanies écoute on peut
dire que les choses ne vont pas mal
aujourd'hui le code mort de monsieur
paul il a demandé que les douze donnes
un soutien de principe à l'idée d'unité
allemande est effectivement les deux
vont probablement publié une déclaration
dans laquelle ils diront que l'unité du
peuple allemand ça serait une bonne
chose ce serait une bonne chose si la
situation en europe est assez calme pour
cela si les rapports et soissons bon
donc sous condition tout de même c'est
un accord de principe qui l'on se
satisfera le chancelier kohl et les
ministres des affaires étrangères des
doses sont en train de mettre en un
texte très nuancée au point dans ce sens
est alors en contrepartie comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur paul se montre très
bons européens puisqu'ils donne son
accord à la mise en route dans un an
avant faire 90 de cette conférence qui
va permettre l'union monétaire la
monnaie européenne si vous voulez votre
question georges apparemment accord sur
l'union monétaire accord sur la charte
sociale
mais l'angleterre fait une nouvelle fois
banda par maguy trouble-fête à nouveau
oui comme on dit ici on fait un accord à
11 à 11 parce que
sa chair ne veut pas de cette monnaie
européenne parce qu'elle pense que ce
serait un abandon de souveraineté pour
l'angleterre que de confier ses intérêts
monétaire un institut fédéral européen
bancaire et puis elle ne veut pas non
plus de la charte sociale la charge
sociale qui proclame solennellement les
droits des travailleurs de tous les pays
d'europe et tous et j'ai un texte
d'inspiration marxiste et je cite donc
elle ne signe pas donc ça aussi c'est un
texte qui a été adopté à 11
en foi de quoi il n'a pas de valeur très
contraignante mais il appartiendra à la
commission c'est à dire à jacques delors
de donner valeur contraignante par une
série de directives
merci georges bortoli à strasbourg vous
savez que cet accord sur la charte
sociale était l'une des priorités de la
présidence française de la communauté
européenne monsieur mitterrand pourra
bien sûr l'occasion de revenir sur ces
dossiers est difficile et changeant de
l'actualité il répondra dimanche soir à
19h sur antenne 2 aux questions de
christine ockrent de serge july de jean
pierre elkabbach et d'alain duhamel dans
une émission spéciale d'une heure quinze
on a donc parlé à strasbourg d'union
monétaire à terme cela veut donc dire
que les européens devraient avoir la
même mené et le même argent est payé
avec les mêmes billets dans n'importe
quel pays d'europe
on en n'est bien sûr pas là mais vous
allez le voir dans ce reportage de
claire chazal et de daniel lévy il y
aurait tout bénéfice pour les
entreprises à ce que cette union soit
déjà fait
à la clé il y a beaucoup d'argent à
économiser la pièce doit être impeccable
car elle va partir équipés des millions
de machines lourdes dans toute l'europe
j'ai deux mpm de 300 personnes est connu
pour son savoir-faire très spécialisés
et parvient aujourd'hui a exporté 30% de
son chiffre d'affaires c'est bien mais
ça veut dire aussi que les comptables
doivent jongler avec une kyrielle de
devises savoir facturer les ventes sans
se tromper en livrant marque mais
surtout bien sûr se protéger contre les
fluctuations des cours des monnaies pour
jean-marie cardo son patron tout cela a
un coût entre le temps passé les la
gestion financière
ça représente à peu près 1% du chiffre
d'affaires consacrés à l'exportation et
en gros ça représente pour nous un demi
million de francs par an et qui plus est
ça n'est pas notre métier nous avons
autre chose à faire nous sommes beaucoup
plus axée sur la conception et la
fabrication de nos équipements que sur
une gestion financière où il peut y
avoir une part de spéculation qui n'est
pas notre métier alors pour l'aider
jean-marie cardo doit le plus souvent
faire appel un ici son banquier une
filiale du cic mais vous connaissez
l'évolution d'un livre actuellement et
je vous le demande de quelle façon
traiter avec les anglais à mohéli que
vous devriez interne puis après on verra
bien sûr j'ai 2ème ne va pas attendre
l'instauration d'une monnaie unique en
europe pour y conquérir de nouveaux
marchés
mais si un jour on pouvait tous traités
en éclats quel gain de temps et d'argent
autre aspect du dossier européen la
charte sociale et l'harmonisation des
lois du travail dans la communauté
l'accord conclu à 11 est un texte qui ne
fait que poser que quelques grands
principes et n'a aucune valeur aucun
aspect contraignant
jean-pierre métivet difficile de
s'entendre à 12 pour forger un socle
social commun à l'europe un exemple
l'âge légal minimum du travail
c'est en france 15 ans ailleurs et
c'était au portugal 14 ans dans la
charte première version présentée par la
commission de bruxelles
la recommandation était de 16 ans mais
entre temps les ministres des affaires
sociales se sont réunis tractations
compromis la charte actuelle fixe l'âge
légal à 15 ans avec même une dérogation
pour les travaux légers deuxième exemple
la durée légale du travail à 39 heures
en france 48 heures en allemagne en
italie au portugal et aucune loi en
angleterre et au danemark
la charte sociale première version
limitée cette durée à 40 heures pour les
jeunes de moins de 18 ans dans le texte
actuel il n'y a plus rien troisième
exemple salaire minimum il est fixé par
la loi en france mais pas en angleterre
par exemple où il est négociée branche
par branche
dans la première charte la commission de
bruxelles caressait l'idée d'un salaire
minimum européen dans le texte actuel
chaque pays conserve ses règles
nationales les critiques de margaret
thatcher aussi du danemark et du
portugal ont peu à peu édulcorée cette
charte c'est tout de même un début qui
permettra à la commission européenne de
proposer des textes d'harmonisation
sociale dans les prochaines années
l'europe de l'est l'effritement des
régimes continuer le doute gangrène
chaque jour un peu plus les partis
communistes il faut désormais décliné
les changements par pays commençons par
l'allemagne de l'est
ce soir c'est dans un gymnase que le
parti communiste est-allemand réunit son
congrès extraordinaire alors que dans le
même temps le chef du gouvernement en ce
monde raw appelle la population au calme
pour éviter le chaos
le parti communiste est-allemand que
l'on voit ici en réunion n'est plus
dirigé après la démission de tous ces
leaders et alors que la chasse ce
mauvais communiste continue l'ancien
secrétaire général du pc erich honecker
avec cinq de ses compagnons de la
direction du parti
devra comparaître en justice pour avoir
porté dommages à l'économie et abusé de
sa fonction au nez caire malade il a 77
ans a été laissé en liberté
ses camarades sont en prison sur place à
berlin est
nous retrouvons notre envoyé spécial
philippe rochot pour une tentative
d'explication
comment le parti communiste est-allemand
at-il pu en quelques jours
voler en éclats quelques jours avant
d'être renversée il chantait
l'internationale sur les marches du
comité central egon krenz et les
dirigeants du sd le parti communiste
est-allemand sont déjà des hommes du
passé
le parti veut freiner sa chute en
parlant de travailler avec les autres
mouvements pour construire une nouvelle
forme de socialisme mais des hommes tels
gunter schabowski responsable du s&ed
pour la région de berlin tentent encore
de s'accrocher au pouvoir
d'autres comme markus wolf ancien chef
des services secrets est allemand le
tombeur de vie liebrandt se présente
aujourd'hui comme un réformateur est un
grand défenseur des libertés
mais la direction de mon parti a eu
tendance jusque-là à réagir plutôt que
d'agir
je pense que nous devons apporter de
nouvelles idées dans l'avenir afin de
renouveler le socialisme dans notre pays
les délégués communistes ont commencé
par engager un débat pour savoir si la
presse allaitent ou non être autorisés à
filmer ses dires les contradictions qui
règne à l'intérieur du parti
cent mille membres ont déjà rendu leur
carte en un mois mais il en reste deux
millions qui demandent un renouvellement
total des thèses du parti mais aussi des
hommes dans le registre plus de
démocratie on annonce également ce soir
à berlin est la création d'une
association des soldats de carrière elle
veut défendre les conscrits est-allemand
et elle est ouverte à tous les citoyens
en union soviétique aussi l'urgence à la
veille d'un hiver qui s'annonce
difficile demain et c'est une première
un samedi il y as réunion extraordinaire
du comité central à moscou à l'ordre du
jour la gravité de la situation
économique
mais on s'attend également
vos voir un ultime règlement de comptes
entre les gorbatchev bien et ce qui
reste des durs une correspondance
téléphonique de moscou de notre envoyé
spécial
gilles rabin a déballé tout entier vit
sur la suppression de l'article 6 de la
constitution l'article sur leurs hauts
dirigeants du parti copine
après la manifestation attire
conservateur de leningrad 48 personnes
défilant pendant plusieurs heures après
l'appel à la grève lancé par andry cac
40 prenant des savants prochain après
surtout l'article publié la semaine
dernière par le capitalisme et à la
social démocratie occidentale
illustration des difficultés que
traverse actuellement l'union soviétique
il ya par exemple cette situation de
confrontation permanente entre les
arméniens et les azéris nous sommes dans
le haut-karabagh il y a un an les
affrontements faisait des dizaines de
morts il y a un an la terre tremblait et
rajoutait au malheur un an après rien
n'a changé au contraire
henri guirchoun et rémy revelin rentrer
du haut karabakh au pied de la falaise
karine taxe est un village arménien a au
dessus
sushi une ville azéri aujourd'hui pour
ceux d'en bas
la vie est devenue impossible
d'en haut les adhérents font tout pour
chasser ces paysans arménien à la nuit
ils tirent des coups de feu lance des
pneus enflammés et des blocs de pierre
qui tombe sur les maisons haut karabagh
ce n'est pas encore la guerre est
presque dans cette voiture tout terrain
des grenades artisanales des bombes
fumigènes
aujourd'hui les arméniens se sont
organisés en milices et des patrouilles
armées circule d'un village à l'autre au
dessus des villages un ballet quotidien
d'hélicoptères le plus sûr moyen
d'assurer le ravitaillement
parfois les hélicoptères aussi peuvent
devenir dangereux les hélicos passe au
dessus de nos fermiers de notre bétail
il leur tire dessus le haut karabakh une
enclave montagneuse coincé entre deux
républiques soviétiques
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan en 1921
staline avait décidé d'en faire une
région autonome mais placé sous la
tutelle de l'azerbaïdjan presque 70 ans
plus tard les arméniens qui sont
majoritaires réclament toujours leur
rattachement à la république d'arménie
notre présence ici calme les esprits
malgré les propos rassurants de cet
officier soviétique depuis plusieurs
mois c'est l' escalade pour répondre au
blocus total imposé par l'azerbaïdjan au
mois d'octobre en pleine nuit un
commando arménien a fait sauter l'un des
principaux ponts de la région
derrière cette violence il y a aussi la
volonté populaire cette femme c'est
jeanne n'a une célèbre actrice du
théâtre de stepanakert au fil des mois
elle est devenue l'une des figures de
proue du mouvement pour le rattachement
à l'arménie et l'an dernier pendant les
grandes manifestations c'est elle qui
galvanisait les foules
maintenant la nuit jalna la pasionaria
fait le tour des villages pour
réconforter ceux qui montent la garde
pour l'instant sable politiques
arméniens ce conflit qui s'enlise risque
aussi d'avoir des conséquences ont pu
quand on consomme encore l'histoire a
montré que l'union soviétique n'existe à
toute évolution
le peuple est habitué à tout aussi c'est
la guerre ça signifie la fin de la
pérestroïka
en attendant pour tenter d'éviter le
pire l'armée verrouille 5500 hommes ont
investi cette région à peine plus grande
qu'un département français ce sont des
forces du ministère de l'intérieur placé
sous le commandement de ce général
en fait la présence de l'armée ne résout
rien ce conflit doit trouver une
solution politique mais coincé entre les
aspirations souvent légitimes des
arméniens et le risque de mécontenter
les azéri et à travers toute la
communauté musulmane à moscou mikhaïl
gorbatchev hésite
alors depuis un an depuis ce tremblement
de terre qui les a frappés
les arméniens en ont assez et comme le
montre ce dessin animé qui circulent
sous le manteau
ils sont décidés coûte que coûte à
obtenir gain de cause
pour refermer ce dossier encore la
bulgarie avec un comité central demain
et à l'instant une dernière minute
monsieur todor jivkov a été exclu du
comité central du parti communiste
bulgare
l'ancien chef du pc et bulgare avait
soixante dix huit ans il avait été
limogé le 10 novembre dernier de son
poste à la tête du parti
suite et fin la tchécoslovaquie monsieur
marianne khalfa le nouveau premier
ministre
tchécoslovaque accepte de former un
nouveau gouvernement comprenant une
moitié de nos communistes
il l'a annoncé tout à l'heure on le voit
ici sur ces images par ailleurs le
dramaturge vaclav havel le leader de la
contestation celui qui a fédéré les
oppositions régime a évoqué la nuit
dernière une hypothèse il pourrait être
candidat au poste honorifique de
président de la république
enfin prague propose à moscou d'ouvrir
des négociations d'experts sur le
retrait du pays des troupes soviétiques
retour en france l'un des huit évadés de
la prison de lannemezan a été retrouvé
dénoncée est arrêtée
isabelle steiss l'étau se resserre
autour des évadés de lannemezan ce matin
la cavale a pris fin pour l'un d'entre
eux olivier l'ip 25 ans a été arrêté
dans cette station de ski près de saint
lary à une dizaine de kilomètres de la
frontière espagnole
blaise est épuisé il n'a opposé aucune
résistance dans un parking une des deux
voitures volées mercredi été retrouvé
d'autres fugitifs ont été aperçus dans
la région il tenterait de passer en
espagne par la montagne ce soit les
gendarmes qu kadri tout le secteur
il reste sept fugitifs tous considérés
comme de dangereux malfaiteurs ils
purgeaient des peines d'au moins 15 ans
leur chef serait philippe etcheverria
auteur d'un hold-up meurtrier dans une
bijouterie de biarritz à lannemezan on
ne comprend toujours pas comment ces
détenus ont pu s'échapper d'un centre
pénitentiaire ultra moderne
les autorités avaient été informés d'un
projet d'évasion évasion qui selon la
chancellerie devait avoir lieu l'année
dernière des mesures de sécurité avaient
donc été renforcée des négligences
ont-elles été commise
une enquête administrative a été ouverte
les sept évadés encore en cavale
pourrait être à l'origine de deux hold
up à pau et à béziers contre une
armurerie une caisse d'epargne le reste
de l'actualité avec l'intifada la
révolution des pierres dans les
territoires occupés par israël la bande
de gaza et ce soir sous couvre-feu
l'armée d'israël est en état d' alerte
maximum pour le deuxième anniversaire du
soulèvement
anne consignes plusieurs accrochages
faisant au moins quatre blessés
aujourd'hui dans les territoires occupés
pour le deuxième anniversaire du
soulèvement palestinien près d'un
million de personnes ont été placées
sous couvre feu
en deux ans du fagace 586 palestiniens
et 38 israéliens ont effectué
question de la france et de l'afrique du
sud sur le mercenaire français bob
denard et les hommes de sa milice pour
qu'ils quittent l'archipel des comores
la france ancienne puissance coloniale
envoie ses hommes et du matériel
militaire à mayotte djibouti la réunion
soit 130 kg de cocaïne saisis par la
douane dans le port de rotterdam une
prise record aux pays bas trois
personnes de nationalité hollandaise ont
été interpellés la drogue a été
découverte dans un conteneur d'un navire
en provenance du surinam
à la bourse de paris l'indicé de
référence est en hausse de 0,69 pour
cents de dollar s'échange à seafrance 05
45 cours officiel
ils sont à deux pas ou presque du pôle
qu'il devrait atteindre dans une petite
semaine l'expédition internationale et
scientifique 30 artica touche au but le
pôle sud et en vue notamment pour jean
louis etienne le français dans quelques
jours ils seront à mi-chemin parti le
premier ou dernier ils ont été retardés
par la violence des conditions météo
claude ai marre
véritable temps de chien avec des
rafales de vent atteignant 160 km/heure
et une température de moins de 35 degrés
et pourtant impossible de s'arrêter trop
longtemps sous peine de rester bloqué
alors il faut continuer même si la
visibilité permet tout juste de voir le
traîneau qui précède
conséquence de ces conditions
épouvantables rencontré mi novembre
l'expédition tu ranges antartica a pris
vie jours de retard sur son programme de
marche ce qui se passe ici quand le vent
souffle c'est que il ya une érosion
éolienne c'est à dire que la glace est
érodée par le vent il ya une poussière
de glace
il appelle sa dulcinée snow c'est une
c'est le bizarre d'encaisser la
poussière de glace qui est balayé et on
vit dans une couche dans une couche de
glace qui est propulsé par le vent qui
vous agréent sur le visage et qui
empêche de voir complètement
heureusement depuis quelques jours le
temps est plus clément hier par exemple
les hommes et déchirante effectué 40 km
à une température de - 27 degrés
actuellement ils sont très proches du
pôle sud après avoir parcouru 2500 km
mais il leur en reste encore 3000 pour
arriver à me renie fin février si tout
va bien si tout va bien les parapluies
de cherbourg certains ont dit que
c'était un film magnifique pas les gens
de cherbourg qui n'ont vu que l'image
déplorable d'une ville où il pleuvait
toujours
autre angoisse plus actuel des citoyens
de la ville des cherbourgeois
il n'y fait pas vraiment toujours chaud
question comment faire pour changer le
temps vincent gerard c'est pascal puyoô
ils sont allés pour cette enquête
météorologiques
demain après midi bien comme à
l'accoutumée c'est à cherbourg qu'il
fera le plus frais avec vous le voyez 6
degrés et voilà cherbourg hérite une
nouvelle fois du bonnet d'âne les villes
frigorifique la classe politique locale
n'avait pas bronché jusque là mais trop
c'est trop
nous étions là c'est de voir que nous
étions toujours en queue au point de vue
images climatologiques et oui cette fois
y en a marre parce que tant de sakania
cherbourg pour tous les téléspectateurs
sakai pareil dans tout le département de
la manche c'est déjà dur d'un pâté la
foule en temps normal mais là c'est même
plus la peine d'essayer
c'était très gênant d'avoir une image
qui était vraiment négative pour le
tourisme donne département difficile en
effet de faire avaler aux touristes que
cherbourg c'est haïti surtout quand la
seule station météo du département situé
ici sur l'aérodrome de maupertus près de
cherbourg
c'est pire que le groenland la
température qui était relevé
actuellement et donc qui servait de base
prévisions qui étaient prises à
maupertus étaient prises à un endroit
qui est pratiquement le le plus froid du
département de la manche
ça suffit les élus manchots se sont donc
retroussés les bras de chemise et ont
trouvé la solution
on va déplacer la station météo dans un
coin plus sympa le tour sera joué
et résultat
ça va créer une augmentation de 2 degrés
environ par rapport à celles qui sont
données pour maupertus actuellement deux
degrés de mieux c'est le paradis la
preuve en était il ne fera plus 18 mai
20 degrés à la belle tactique qui a dit
que les hommes politiques étaient à
court d'idées 1 ça y est la manche tient
son nouveau look la manche n'en va avoir
le look que et qu'elle a mais que c'est
pas le look qu'on lui donne avec la
météo
le nom de la nouvelle station météo et
déjà trouvé cher bora bora
comme la musique a changé
il y à un tiercé demain en guerre voici
les pronostics de pierrette brès 20
partants le 5 le 6 le vin et le 17 le 13
le 11 le 12 et le 19
dans un instant après bien sûr la météo
de jeu et dans la pierre où on ne vous
dira qu'il fait toujours beau à
cherbourg vous avez rendez vous avec le
téléthon qui a démarré il y à une heure
et demie maintenant trente heures
d'exploit de variétés pour simplement
souligner la solidarité nécessaire
dernier journal sur antenne 2 ce soir
philippe gassot demain pour les éditions
du week end vous retrouverez betty
dureau et daniel bilalian à bientôt
excellente soirée à tous sur antenne 2